imagine fitting into those jeans that
are in the back of your closet
and feeling confident in that dress
again well here to tell us how you can
do that is brittany black with the jazzy
wellness to tell us more
about the treatment now it's called body
sculpting brittney
what can you tell us about this
treatment
um it's a completely non-invasive no
downtime treatment
fda approved to help you lose that
stubborn body fat that you just can't
seem to get rid of
now this is not just a treatment that
you talk about you've actually
done this treatment before can you tell
us like where did you have it done did
you have
certain problem areas that you wanted to
work on
i did so for me a trouble area is my
stomach
from losing weight and gaining weight
that skin laxity doesn't stay the same
and it's a really stubborn area to
target with diet and exercise so
sometimes you need a little help
well tell us how it works you you can
actually just go in and there's no
downtime what exactly happens during the
process
so we start off by liquefying the fat
cells
then we go in with a different
technology that permanently kills the
fat
then we go in with a different
technology to tighten the skin
so it's all completely permanent
completely non-invasive
it's all fda approved technology so it's
very safe
now how many sessions are needed to
achieve
these ideal results typically four
sessions
and we like to do them once a week
sometimes a little bit extra time in
between
now those those pictures just speak for
themselves
as far as how quickly you will see the
results will you see them
after one session yep typically on your
first session
we'll see two to three inches but we've
had people lose up to seven
now how long does a treatment take are
we going to be there for a few hours
is that is it quick what is it like
it's one hour and the technician is in
the room with you the entire time
which is great it's a very hands-on
approach so if there's any
specific stubborn areas you want to
focus on not just the whole stomach
so like if there's just a little area
you want them to focus on you can
physically tell them to do that
that's just uh looking at those results
that is just
amazing the before and afters on this
now
as far as who this treatment is perfect
for who would you recommend
body sculpting to the treatment is for
everybody we have
male female patients we have patients
that are looking to get rid of just
a little bit and some patients who are
looking to get rid of a lot
so there's no cap to it there's no
special requirements it's for everybody
is there any pain
associated with it there's not we
actually have patients that fall asleep
and they say it feels like a hot stone
massage
so not bad for losing a few inches well
thank you so much brittany that's great
information you can try it yourself at
the jazzy wellness
at 900 south valley view boulevard
that's sweet 100 or you can call them at
702-800-7406 or go
to thejazzywellness.com they'll
guarantee that you'll lose two inches
the same day
and for the first 10 callers you will
get forty percent off
of the series of body contouring so
check it out we'll be right back